protesters are locked in a tense
standoff with federal agents
[Music]
and it's getting increasingly dangerous
neither side seems willing to back down
on an 11th night of clashes in portland
fireworks are thrown in
and tear gas is fired back
it's now a familiar pattern of
engagement
this tear gas is being fired through
every few minutes to try and push
protesters back but so many here have
become so
used to this they come ready
a large number of protesters are in gas
masks
their efforts feel coordinated leaf
blowers used
to disperse the cs gas the troops are
here to protect the federal courthouse
pummel the fence angry at their
uninvited involvement
[Music]
rubber bullets are fired back but the
tactics of protesters
feels increasingly hostile too laser
pens used to obscure agents vision
the white house has said three officers
have suffered eye injuries
some feel their protests have been
hijacked by this violence
before they showed up there were 200
people here at night
now look around would you call yourself
an anarchist
how would you describe yourself i'm here
fighting for the rights the basic rights
of every single human being in this
country
the city's strong sense of activism has
seen largely peaceful protests against
racial injustice
every night since the killing of george
floyd
more than eight weeks ago but after
president trump sent him
federal forces to protect federal
statutes
anger has grown and now nightly violence
how do you feel that this protest this
movement that you believe in that
brought you out here to the streets
[Music]
i believe there is a certain pressure
needed there is a certain presence and
protests needed
the bodies and the faces and the voices
are needed
the fire works or not the tearing down
the fence thinking you're going to go
into a building with a million bullets
in it or not
our interview was interrupted by tear
gas like so much of the change
people were demanding in the streets
interrupted by this unrest many u.s
cities do need help
but not help like this but it's not
clear
how it will end sally look with sky news
portland